هدفا عربي واحد كفيل بموجه من الاحتفال
تنطلق من جبال الاطلس الى جبال قنديل
الجديده منها والقديمه ومن باب مراكش الى
باب العمود وكان حدود سايكس بيكو اختفت
فجاه من المشهد فما الذي حدث في قطر
[تصفيق]
العقال صوت الاذان الحجاب يصلون يؤدون
صلاتهم مشاهد لطالما عملتها الافلام
الغربيه للتسويق لفكره التخلف واحيانا
الارهاب بنظره الاستعلائيه واستشراقيه
صدقها احيانا حتى العرب وانفسه لن تخفي
قطار هذه العناصر في استضافتها للمونديال
بالابرزاتها ووضعتها امام العالم في رساله
تقول هذه حضارتنا العربيه والاسلاميه
واهلا بكم للتعرف عليها بشكل مباشر دون
عدسات كاميرا او اعلى منه فهل نجحت في ذلك
رجل اجنبي يجلس في سوق واقف يرتدي غتره
تحمل على بلاده سيدات اجنبيات يرتدين
الحجاب ويستمعنا للشرح في المسجد الفريق
الانجليزي يجري تدريباته على صوت الاذان
حدث عالمي نعم لكنه بطبع عربي واسلامي
نجحت قطر من خلاله في ايصال الشعور لاي
عربيه وطى ارضها انه هو من يصنع الحدث انه
صاحب المكان للضعيف ليتحمل المسؤوليه
عن الثقافه العربيه والاسلاميه فاحسن
الاستقبال كانه بيتهم
شيء ما حدث في قطر
العربيه هل هناك شيء تغير عن نسبه للعالم
كله بان الدول العربيه قادره على تحقيق
الانجازات والنهوض مره اخرى امام العالم
كله بزاف الكلب البلدان كل اخوان العرب
الافارقه المسلمين المشجعيننا فرحانين
بزاف
انه الدول العربيه مثلا او الشعب انه قادر
يعمل انجازات قادر توحد قادر يقرب
المسافات همم
جاي من غزه عشان يحضر القائم تبع المغرب
العربي
الاتحاد الدول العربيه
في قطر جميع الدول العربيه متسانده ومسكات
في يد واحده يعني ما شاء الله
كانك تحيث تراثا من الامل لدى شعوب عن
حربيه
تراث المتعلق بالامه وتراث قديم ومتجدل في
الشعوب حتى ولو كانت التنشئه الاجتماعيه
للدول الوطنيه ادت الى فقدان بعض من
المميزات التي تجمع العرب الشعور بالعربيه
فعلا تجاوزت الدول الوطنيه بشكل كبير لان
ارتاها وتراثها وعلاقتها مع بعض العلاقات
يعني الاجتماعيه هي من تتحدث وليست تنشئه
الاجتماعيه للدوله الوطنيه ليست الوطنيه
هي التي تتحدث
اللي جاي من نواف في شيشه جاي من نواف في
شيء جاي من النواف
ويسدد هدف الانتصار في شباك الارجنتين
بوخلال يقنص المرمى البلجيكي وبونو يقف
جدارا عازلا ويقول اسبانيا لن تمر قد
يراها البعض مجرد لعبه هذا صحيح لكنك
كثيرين يرونها معيارا لامور اكبر
في مباراه كره القدم
عن نفسه يرى نفسه احيانا اقل من ان يفوز
ان يتقدم ان ينتصر اليوم رسمت في ذاكرتنا
صوره انتصار تغدو رمزا والرمز يقلد والنصر
يجروا اخر
كان لذلك الهدف اثر الفراشه ليس فقط على
الجماهير وانما على الفرق العربيه
المشاركه ايضا فبعد فوز السعوديه تعادل كل
من المغرب وتونس فما كان اثر ذلك الفوز
[تصفيق]
للعرب انطلاقه جيده
منطقه النفس الثقه في النفس هل جعلت من
المنتخبات العربيه ان تعرف ان هناك ما
يسمى كسر الحاجز كسر الحاجز هذا رفع مسقط
الطموح
ومن بعدها قطر وتونس قال البعض فلنستيقظ
من الحلم ونعيش الواقع والواقع في عقول
الكثيرين هو ان تلعب المنتخبات العربيه في
دور المجموعات لتخرج خلاله او في افضل
الاحوال بعده وباداء المشرف لكن كان
للزكريا بخلال راي اخر هز الشباك بلجيكا
بهدف ثامن اسود الاطلس تصحح النصر ليس
حلما فقط واستعدوا لواقع جديد
ما حدث في مونديال قطر هو ان الشباب
العربي
ليس بعيده وانه بامكاننا ان نجتمع حول
البطاله
حتى اعتدنا في موروثنا الثقافيه مفهوم
الهزيمه
اليوم ننجز وننتصر والانتصار اشعل الفرح
[تصفيق]
حكومه الاسرائيليه لم تهاجم بعد المغاربه
اليهود الذين حملوا الاعلام في بعض
المناطق في اسرائيل لكن هاجموا
الفلسطينيين في حبيباتهم عندما حملوا
الاعلام المغربيه بجانب الاعلام
الفلسطينيه الاعلام المغربي الان ليس على
موطني هو علم يتعلق بالعرب بالعربي
كماساه فقط يخرج لنصرتها في عاصمه بلادي
كل ما قصفت اسرائيل غزه مونديال قطر كان
من المناسبات القليله التي ارتبطت فيها
القضيه
بظرف ايجابي بظرف انتصار ولهذا وقع كبير
على الفلسطينيين والعرب كافه وربما هذا ما
يثير مخاوف اسرائيل
اليوم وتسالت عما اذا كانت الفيفا ستفرض
عقوبه على المنتخب المغربي لحمله
يا قطر ورفع العلم الفلسطيني في الدوحه
والعالم المغربي في القدس احتفالا بنفس
الحدث
بها
من الامور الجميله التي لفتتني في هذا
المونديال محمد وليد الرجراجي عندما قال
بالمغربيات الدارجه وعلاش من الاحلام مش
ناخذ الكاس هذا الشخص كان موجها للجماهير
ايضا وليس فقط مدربا للفريق دير النيه
كلمه تنبع من ثقافتنا الدينيه واجتماعيا
حتى ان امهاتنا تقول دائما عين خير
الام الام البسيطه التي تخرج الى الملعب
بجلبابها الذي نعرف جميعا هذه الام تمثل
اي ام مغربيه او عربيه او مسلمه التي تلعب
دورا في حياه ابنائها لكي يحققوا انجازات
كبيره هذه الام كان لديها دورا فعال في
انجازات المنتخب المغربي
[موسيقى]
قطر شروط الجديده
والحضاريه وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل لتعارفوا
كسر المشهد الغربيه
الشاب غالب المفتاح النبي مثلا بلد المضيف
هو من ذوي التحديات الممثل الشهير مرجان
فيمن من ذوي البشاره السمراء الذي انتقدت
صحيفه المشاركته وقالت من مثل في ادوار
علمانيه يشارك اليوم في افتتاح وصفاته
الدينيه والفنان القطري دادا التي قطعه
الزي القطريه وغنت في الافتتاح بمظهرها
الاعتياديه تكسير صوره النبطيه للاستعراض
الشرط في مشاركه النساء في حديث
الاخر حاولت بعض الجهات فيها حسب اعظم
منها واعلامها عن الرؤيا لاننا ما جاء
بهما
صوره النمطيه التي الصقتها بالعربي نظره
الاستعلائيه احيانا بعد قضاياها اسماء
واعلى من قضايا الاخ لكن قطر قالت ستعقدون
بعين الاعتبار معير غيركم وثقافته
واستعداده او عدم استعداده لتقبل فكره
الناس لكن ماذا عن استعدادكم انتم بتقبل
افكار الغير ومعاييره كان مونديلا عربيا
بامتياز وفي الوقت الذي ابهرت به قطر
العالم بتنظيم والاستقبال المغرب اهلا
وسهلا